I know there's gonna be a lot of
situations or I'm just gonna have no
clue what to do we are all about to
spend the next three months obsessing
over Joe Joe Fletcher and her journey i
sat down with the new bachelorette ahead
of Monday night's premiere to find out
exactly what fans can expect Ben did
very famously infamously say I love you
to you and Lauren B's what are your
feelings on saying I love you to
multiple people I thought about this you
know I haven't been in the situation
that Ben was in I'm about to be put in
that situation I think that it's
definitely possible to love people in
different ways but I think I will be
very careful to say that to more than
one person I just wouldn't want just to
hurt somebody in that way what qualities
are you looking for honestly I would
just want someone who is genuine and
makes me laugh and is my best friend
what about deal-breakers what are yours
oh my gosh you know someone who's just
arrogant and thinks that they know
everything they're so cool and I can't
deal with that Ben was known as the
perfect 10 that was kind of his nickname
the perfect guy what will Joe Joe be
known as I just am really trying to stay
myself throughout this whole thing and
I'm a little weird sometime then I
sometimes don't have a filter on what
I'm thinking and I just really want to
stay myself throughout this whole thing
and I want whoever I pick to know me for
exactly who I am